the Ross Ice Shelf team is at a dead
stop in a growing storm 100 miles from
help you out you in the middle of
nowhere no one's really been here before
your life is in danger if you go outside
and hang around in there too long
rob has to change a flat tire on the
lead vehicle in the middle of whiteout
conditions before they can get moving
again I told him I'm just gonna back it
up onto that block a little bit and then
I'll come out and we'll set this up and
then as I draw it back hopefully it'll
just push those tracks apart we can whip
that out yeah good
I had no idea that I could go wrong on a
Pistenbully I just assumed that you just
drive on the tracks I am NOT a mechanic
but Rob's an amazing mechanic now we're
cooking you can see that it's got a
gouge out of the side here so the ice
just ripped into the point of that
there's snow and ice conditions you get
an intact the current like really
anywhere else in the world
you just got to manage it we've got the
spare tire
working in places like this it's not
always about what you want to do or hey
you want to do it that's it's almost
entirely what you have to do it was all
right the team has only been stopped for
45 minutes but conditions have gotten
much worse
that's windy these blowing snow and then
affects your visibility it gets quite
difficult to drive it's kind of getting
to the point where it's really only a
couple of options or you reckon we have
to make a call either make camp for the
night or push on try and make up a bit
more time yeah
the reality is we have to stop
everything today where we are hunker
down keep everybody warm from now with
what we can see out there it's probably
just not worth going anywhere so it's a
shame to lose one day you know one of
our weather days even when we're not
even doing the science but you know what
definitely display it down